a North Carolina hospitals pioneering
use of drones to speed up the delivery
of critical medical supplies across its
campus now the drones carry blood and
other lab supplies for wake med hospital
it's history-making partnership with UPS
is giving us a glimpse at how drones
deliveries could help save lives Kris
Van Cleave is at wake med hospital in
Raleigh with more on this story Chris
good morning to you good morning this is
the quadcopter that's making history it
uses this down here to make its
deliveries to a lab here on the wake med
campus is about three quarters of a mile
away and to walk it takes about 45
minutes but up there it's less than a
four-minute flight this drone takes off
from the front lawn of wake med hospital
eight times a day it's a race against
time carrying medical supplies like
blood to a lab across this sprawling 1
million square-foot medical campus this
is one of our technicians and his job is
to deliver the payload box it came over
on the drug to our personnel here the
pioneering program is the brainchild of
dr. Stuart Ginn a former United Airlines
pilot we were interested in speeding
ride reliability he saw a way to speed
up diagnosing patients we're talking
about shaving off 30 minutes to 3 hours
easily from our former lab and an lab
which means faster results so faster
answers for his patients to do it wake
med partnered with shipping giant UPS
and drone maker matter net to launch the
program in March
the first revenue-producing commercial
drone flights approved by the FAA the
eight flights carrying in large medical
campuses hospital campuses in urban
environments dan Gagnon is the UPS vice
president of healthcare strategies when
we look at the turnaround times and how
important it is to get blood work in and
the results turned back around it's a
critical space last month the University
of Maryland Medical Center completed the
first organ donor drone delivery for a
transplant something that could make
organ delivery safer and cheaper but the
FAA has been slow to regulate an
industry that's already taking off fast
it's expected to hit twenty nine billion
dollars within eight years Google backed
wing is the first company to receive FAA
approval for drone delivery to goods to
businesses and homes the app-based
service is already operating in
Australia and soon in Finland it will
begin in Virginia later this year we've
never been able to receive goods that
fast
mark banks is the director of Virginia
Tech's drone program which partnered
with wing the biggest challenge for
drone delivery mainstream will probably
be public acceptance to be honest now we
need to talk with the communities and
figure out how to integrate this in a
way that's beneficial for everyone at
wake med dr. gin believes these drones
will soon fly between hospitals miles
apart and one day become a link to
remote rural hospitals so that maybe the
patient don't even have to come here
right and maybe they can be cared for at
that smaller facility this is part of a
three-year pilot program to see how the
drones integrate into the airspace here
in Raleigh but UPS believes it is
something that could be replicated at
hospital systems across the country
Norah what a fascinating story Chris
thank you